it was really just me my mom
my mom was
a wild card to put it best what are you
doing
there were a few things she was afraid
of ever
okay now my Chloe girl
[Music]
oh it should be happy I want you to
travel
[Music]
my mother's name was Jennifer joy and
she really lived that up nothing really
worried her
[Music]
rent is due it'll be fine it'll be fine
when I was 16 for a couple of weeks I
went to go stay with a friend in
California
and before I left I told my mom you
really need to get that mole on your
chest looked at it's it's looking really
gnarly and just like she always did it
was
no big deal it was gonna be fine
[Music]
it was
melanoma
while I was gone they went to remove it
they did a full body scan and that is
when they found a golf ball sized
foreign
[Music]
it's like trimming a weed you can trim
it down but it's going to keep growing
back because we can't get to the root of
it and take it out it's it has a place
to continue coming back
at the beginning of my sophomore year of
college I remember the day my mom told
me she was pregnant and Along Came my
sister Charlotte and from that point on
it was just head over heels in love with
Charlotte
[Music]
you do it so when Charlotte was about a
year old I was again I was in college
my mom had been driving on her way back
from her doctor was stationed in
Nashville within the hour she got a
phone call she just fell apart she
really broke down because
you know you don't have to answer the
phone to know what that means
they told me you know we need to
schedule a surgery within the week and
it is back and it has come back very
aggressively
[Music]
surgery removed what they could
stapled it all back together
and this time they chose to be a little
bit more aggressive with treatment she
was a lot more tired this time
[Music]
again she got better she began traveling
again she she would Foster animals and
she would take up new crafts and you
know Charlotte was getting older that
was around the time that I met my
husband
about a month into our relationship I
was just like listen this has been fun
and all but I need you to know there's
gonna come a day when
my mom isn't here anymore
okay now my Chloe girl
[Music]
I want you to be happy I want you to
travel
I I became a realist very young
and Charlotte's gonna end up being mine
I was flirting with the idea of eloping
in Jamaica
[Music]
just like but I don't want to hurt you
I continue to travel it's a beautiful
new things
[Music]
make sure you see the waterfalls
I began leaning into
my baking
I'd grown somewhat of a social media
audience I wasn't just sharing my baking
I was also sharing some of my personal
life and it was right in the middle of
that when I was about six months
pregnant that my mom called me and said
that it was back
[Music]
I was extremely extremely overwhelmed
and extremely scared I was having panic
attacks on the regular and I chose to
talk about it and I was using my social
media to do that
today was the hardest day of my life we
have the results from Mom's CT scan and
MRI
someone sent her flowers and I cannot
thank you enough for how kind that was
we really started building a community
that was bigger than a customer base or
something we were building something
that was
people cared about my mom and remembered
the things that happened to her six
months prior and were praying for her
that's such an immensely touching thing
to do for a stranger
I don't know how much I damaged
whatever he was leaving one behind
I think after that third time that it
came back from my mom
is when she had a really drastic shift
in her health
essentially what became clear over the
next week was that she was not doing
well
[Music]
they were going to go in and they were
going to relieve pressure and put her on
some very very serious steroids
but if that doesn't work and this
continues to get bad they're not going
to be able to do anything anymore
[Music]
it was swelling on the brain again
at the end of it all the thing that
brought my mom to the end was
it wasn't the brain tumor it was the
amount of times that she tried to get
rid of the brain tumors that scar tissue
I had spoken to my mother's
neuro-oncologists she said there isn't
going to be another option anymore
unfortunately there is no Doctor Who's
going to consider an invasive surgery
anymore I know you love your mother but
it's time to think about her quality of
life it's time to think about our
comfort
[Music]
I was really beating myself up for not
being able to save her
and I was telling her I'm so so sorry I
just wanted to make you proud she
squeezed out I am proud
um that was probably the last thing she
ever said
[Music]
my Chloe girl
I'm sorry to leave you with all this on
your hands my baby
never meant to
I want you to be happy I want you to
travel
[Music]
continue to travel it's a beautiful new
things I love you more than you can now
please take good care of jolly
like I would I love you my girl
hang in there keep plugging away and
fighting
thank you
[Music]
there is a girl hanging by her broken
leg from the telephone wire
I didn't need several ambulances
how many people three you really need to
hurry